- Oh, I'm so excited.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Welcome back, you two.
You've been here before remotely.
- Yes. Yes, happy to be here in person.
- But you so last and
welcome to the rest of you.
Yes, I love the film so much.
We're gonna get to it
but I have to say the last
time you were here, Jeff
we were naming my band
and we settled on Y'all.
Do you approve it?
Doesn't matter, I'm not changing it,
but do you like it?
- I like it fine.
Your band could be called anything.
They'd be great.
I have an idea.
- Okay.
- Hey, you know, I have a little band.
And we made an album the
last time that Miley Cyrus,
and Fiona Apple sang on.
If you would sing on our
next little recording
- If you would ask me
- Would you please?
- Yes.
- I have an idea.
(audience cheering and group laughing)
- Jeff's out here making moves.
- Wait. No, no,
we've actually done this
together on "Hollywood Game Night".
We were both on the same team.
We sang a little together.
- I have an idea for a song.
- Okay.
- Don't fence me in.
- Do you know that?
- No.
♪ Give me land, lots of land. ♪
♪ BA da, da, bazidagaba. ♪
♪Don't fence me in. ♪
- I like that.
- Okay, I like this.
I don't like to be pigeonholed, I'm in.
- What are y'all, there was
an inside joke or something.
Y'all laughed that way.
- Well I mean, Jeff Goldblum is a genius,
a bonafide genius.
- He's actually insane on a piano.
Like, I didn't know.
And then I was like, what?
Like we were playing some game thing,
and I was like, I'm sorry, what?
- It's true.
So whenever he says I have an idea,
something marvelous is gonna follow it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So that's what he said.
He goes, Hey, Hey, I have an idea.
And we were like,
- Tell us.
- Also, all I want from today is
for you two to sing.
So I was like, it was really close.
I just got really close.
- It was so close.
Well, we're gonna do it now.
You all heard it?
- Yes.
- There's no takebacks, Jeff.
- [Bryce] There are witnesses.
- [Kelly] No takebacks.